Je dois constituer une équipe et faire de notre
mieux pour protéger les bâtiments, les ponts et les
œuvres d'art avant que les nazis ne détruisent tout.
Combien ont rencontré six Jésus bien avec vous à
sept heures, c'est bien mieux, Monsieur le Président, nous
sommes à un point de cette guerre qui est le
plus  dangereux pour les plus grandes
réalisations connues de l'homme Hitler le
voulait vraiment, tous ces gars risquent leur
vie pour sauver notre histoire et notre
culture communes, cela ne fait aucun doute,
c'est la plus grande chasse au trésor
jamais vue.
Les Monuments Men sont une équipe de
spécialistes envoyés en France pour
récupérer les naazi, c'étaient des hommes qui avaient
bien au-delà de l'âge où ils allaient
être enrôlés dans la guerre pour poursuivre
cet art et essayer de le sauver. C'est cette
incroyablement noble entreprise, les œuvres d'art
auraient été appropriées par un pouvoir
qui n'avait pas le droit de le faire.
Si la mission elle-même est très
dangereuse, les nazis sont en fuite mais
ils emportent tout avec eux, l'
enfer se déchaîne ici et une partie de l'
intrigue de ce film est le décret Néron d'Hitler
qui disait que si quelque chose
lui arrivait, tout ce qu'ils avaient
volé devait être détruit quelle est la
vie de tous ces gens la guerre touche à sa
fin et tout le monde se rapproche de Berlin
c'est votre responsabilité maintenant Hitler est
mort 6 millions de pièces c'est rôle les
Allemands en auraient fait exploser une grande partie
ils avaient des bombes de deux tonnes  un peu de
Mind Frank nous devons
partir, sortons
d'
ici si vous détruisez une génération entière
de culture populaire, c'est qu'ils n'ont
jamais existé, c'est ce que veut Hitler
et c'est la seule chose que nous ne pouvons pas permettre,
c'est si rare de faire une histoire  que les gens
ne savent pas que c'est un film de braquage et un
film de guerre et qu'il s'agit de gens
prêts à tout sacrifier pour sauver
ce qu'il y a de meilleur en nous, l'
humanité, pour The Monuments
Men